hello and welcome to the 17th PHP
tutorial in this tutorial we're gonna be
something a little more interesting
because I'm getting sort of bored let's
close out of that header file now we'll
leave it included just for fun and we're
gonna do now is let's go over let's do a
full and go over like this mission of a
form and then usually you'll have some
sort of string data and then we can kind
of save way into dealing with string
data and while at the same time dealing
with forms chances are if you're gonna
make a webpage that isn't totally static
you'll have some sort of form submission
going on so let's go with our outside of
our PHP here and do some HTML so we're
going to just do a typical form here and
we're gonna say so whose form action
equals and this will just be PHP
tutorials dot PHP or whatever your your
file name is and then method is going to
be equal to host now our form we're
going to just specify some size and
information for a form and it's going to
be a text area name is going to be equal
to tags let's just say we've got whoops
rows equals 7 and columns
equals
let's do 45 close this off open and then
we'll just finish off our text area tag
then we'll follow with a couple breaks
so this our text area is done and then
you're going to usually have some sort
of submit button you know whatever so
that's all we had a couple breaks and
then we're going to have input and the
type is going to be equal to submit
shall it'll be you know submit input
type and the value ie the title that
will be on that box I don't know I can't
think of a better word besides submit
sorry to be boring but that's the best
word for it and that'll be that and then
we'll close off our form tag with the
beautiful standards so now that we've
got this form let's save that and look
at it and make sure you know along the
way that we're doing everything right
continue okay and we've we've got this
form it's a text box and lovely Google
lets us do all kinds of things in this
text box and we type in this sex box
and we can hit a submit button but it's
not doing anything besides taking us to
this page so we want to do something
besides you know retaking us back to
this page let's pop back over here and
let's actually make something that
actually does something so within our
actual PHP tags we're going to start
specifying some statements now the first
thing we want to know is did they hit
the submit button right because we don't
wanna do anything if they didn't hit the
submit button so first what you want to
do is if in your parameters and then are
the group sees if
and then you use the is set and then you
put in here the parameters and in this
case we want to check post and then text
now so what this is asking is if is set
did the person click the post right and
it's referring to text this text area so
now if they did do this what we want to
do is we're going to say our variable
text equals dollar underscore post and
this is just like built into Python or
PHP my goodness I'm doing it again I was
doing good for a while
text so this was just an if statement
asking if this occurred and if it did
then we're gonna say okay text equals
that occurrence then what we want to do
is let's go ahead and just spit out the
text right let's say text and then so we
can later on do more stuff on page we'll
save the text and then we want like a
line break basically now if so this is
asking did they press the submit button
so if they did then good and then the
next question is going to be in tells
actually that's not doing else only
let's just only do something if they
could select the it otherwise no it's
not going to do anything doesn't make
any sense so if they do this we want to
echo it out but now what we'd like to do
is throw in another if statement if
the using the exclamation mark for not
empty so if it's not empty what we want
to do is and actually you got it with an
empty you have to specify the variable
that we're referring to and in this case
it's text so if that's not empty then
what we want to do is echo submitted
text and because what we're gonna do is
start manipulating the text so we've
already spit it out once well if it's
not empty don't want to maybe perform
something with it so say you want to
make a forum or something like that if
they hit the submit button you
definitely do want to do something right
but what you want to do is kind of
dependent on did they enter some things
I mean I'm sure you've used a form
before and at times maybe miss clicked
the submit button or something like that
so let's say you want to echo the
submitted texts in this case with a
couple of breaks
oh we didn't close it off and then we
want to echo or submit yours echoing out
like the text of submitted text then you
want to actually echo out the text now
if there's no text I don't want to you
know there's nothing gonna be echoed out
so you'd want to explain like okay well
what happened why aren't I seeing any
text so you want to echo out no text has
been entered so we save that and let's
run it and hopefully won't make us any
errors and so it just went over our
submitted text basically so that lets
visit this page button and say here it
is
sample text submit and then it spits up
the submitted text here and then later
on it submits the text again down here
but really what I want to do is we're
gonna start doing some stream
manipulation so that's why we're gonna
have two of these so anyways this is a
basic submit form with that I'm just
going to say don't leave this on your
page just yet don't get excited and like
leave my tutorials thinking like okay I
know how to do the rest of the stuff so
maybe you do but there's one more caveat
that I have to give you and if you want
that caveat you'll have to watch the
next tutorial